ok mais le remplaçant arrive quand
personne de disponible une personne
grand tritiée presqu'île de rhuys bashir
lazar je viens pour le poste c'est juste
qu'il ya des procédures à suivre j'ai
enchaîné pendant 19 ans dans une école
primaire âge et moi je suis disponible
tout de suite
on va placer les pupitres rangées bien
droite
on va faire une petite dictée qui
sauvent savoir où l'on paie pour le
niveau des dictées faudra aux injustices
et de tirer de la peau de chagrin dans
l'eure et de balzac que vous connaissez
sans que jamais
bien
respectée nous on est plus dans les
années 80 la normale
n'est jamais tout à fait normal en
algérie tu n'y arriveras j'angoisse pour
les petits je les imagine toujours
devenu grand brésil pas encore que des
enfants
c'est une force et maria d une nuance
que vous échappe après ça c'est sûr que
on préfère que vous contentiez
d'enseigner dans pote éduquer notre vie
une 13e année 2 c'est un insecte
entre la folie et le papillon
dans un petit cocon fragile bientôt prêt
à déployer ses ailes comme vous
tous
et vous